hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
the secondary structures of protein and
in that context we would talk about beta
plated sheets
previously we have talked about alpha
helices if you missed that video go
check that video and the link is in the
i button
so protein structure can be divided into
different structural levels
starting from primary structure then
secondary structure
tertiary and quaternary structure and
now we are focusing on the secondary
structural
features among the secondary structural
features there could be alpha helices
there could be beta turns
there could be beta pleated sheet the
center stage of this video would deal
with
beta pleated sheet now beta plated sheet
is a
region of peptide chain
where the amino acids are linked
with each other in a specific
orientation
in form of hydrogen bonding and this
kind of gives like a sheet
a sheet like appearance in a 3d space
and that is why the name is beta pleated
sheet so let's look at
the structural features of this so
the nh groups of the backbone
actually forms hydrogen bonds with the
carbonyl group
from the other amino acids so roughly
it looks like this now
the biggest difference between alpha
helices and beta plated sheet
is the distance between adjacent amino
acid
which is 1.5 am strong in alpha helices
whereas it is 3.5 m strong
in beta pleated sheet so in terms of
steric hindrance
beta plated sheet structures experience
experience
less steady constraint compared to alpha
helices
now beta plated sheet can be
organized into two different orientation
parallel
and antiparallel in this particular
orientation
you can understand the beta plated sheet
has all the hydrogen bonds in a
particular plane
right in a planar fashion and all the
amino acid r groups are protruding out
from the plane either upwards or
downwards
that itself is reducing the steric
constraint
right now let me tell you due to these
kind of structural
organization tryptophan tyrosine
phenylalanine these kind of
bulky side chain containing amino acid
can be a part of beta pleated sheet
but this is not a stereotype there are
many other structures
where beta plated sheet generally
prefers smaller side chain
containing amino acid as well
and probably due to the structural
feature of beta plated sheet these kind
of
bulky groups can fit
now if we look at the beta plated sheet
in a
uh ramachandran plot we would see
the phi and psi angle would be roughly
minus 120 degree and plus
115 degree roughly they fall into this
particular region
both parallel and anti-parallel sheets
fall into this region
now the question is where do we found
find the beta plated sheets
it turns out many protein contains both
alpha helices
or beta plated sheet as their secondary
structures
but the proportion is different some
proteins might be enriched in beta
plated sheet
while some others are enriched in alpha
helices
just to give you an example the silk
or fibroin this particular protein
is very much enriched in beta pleated
sheet
now the supramolecular association of
beta plated sheet
has been implicated in neurodegenerative
diseases like alzheimer's
where it can form aggregation
so beta plated sheet their interaction
with each other
is very important in context of disease
now let me tell you that how structural
features
of proteins can be studied using
experimental techniques
like how we can experimentally determine
the changes at the level of beta plated
sheet or alpha helices
techniques like x-ray crystallography or
circular dichroism spectroscopy could be
useful
to study these features so if you want
to learn
about these specific techniques the link
would be provided in the i button
now here let me tell you about circular
dichroism spectroscopy
looking at the cd signature you can
understand whether that particular
protein is majorly
constituted with alpha helix or beta
plated plated sheet let's take one
example
look at this particular dotted line this
is the protein signature
or cd signature of a particular protein
now comparing with known signature
you can kind of understand this protein
would be
majorly made up of alpha helices
then coming to the next particular
example
where we see a stress like this this
particular protein
looks like it is going to be majorly
constituting of beta plated sheet
apart from these techniques cryo
electron microscopy can
also provide us with the structural
information about
a protein so in this video what we have
learned
is the structure of beta plated sheet
where we can find them etc
but this beta plated sheet can also
coordinate with alpha helices
and form super secondary structures so
there are different levels of structural
complexity
and gradually we would level up so
in upcoming videos you would get much
more
information about super secondary
structures which might have alpha
helices
in combination with beauty plated sheets
so just to summarize what we have
learned so far
we learned about the structural features
of beta plated sheet how they are
oriented
in a 3d space the dihedral angles where
they fall in
ramachandran plot we also looked at the
factor that can govern the
stereo specificity or specificity or the
stability of the depleted sheet
lastly we also learn the possible ways
by which we can
take a look at the structural features
of be depleted sheet
so if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe
and thanks for listening see you next
time